um kurz nach 10 in berlin schöneberg
versammelt sich die berliner unterwelt
der berühmte clan boss arafat abou
chaker trauert am grab seiner mutter
200 polizisten sichern die umgebung des
zwölf apostel friedhofs in berlin
schöneberg verfügen wird jeder holos
jetzt die chance nutzen und seine mutter
geräusche und nicht von uns alle rechte
700 gäste kommen zur beerdigung arafats
mutter nazmi abou chaker
alarmbereitschaft bei der berliner
polizei
sie richten kontrollpunkte für die
trauernden ein achten darauf dass die
hygiene und abstandsregeln eingehalten
werden die kriminelle großfamilien abou
chaker besteht aus sechs söhnen und drei
töchtern alle der sechs söhne sind in
der berliner unterwelt bekannte clown
posse prostitution groß diebstähle
freiheitsberaubung schwere
körperverletzung oder erpressung sie
scheinen von nichts zurückzuschrecken
arafat abou chaker ist der kopf der
bande
doch so geknickt wie heute am grab
seiner mutter sieht man den 44 jährigen
nur selten aktuell steht arafat mit drei
seinen brüdern vor gericht es geht um
den streit mit rapper bushido
am montag war die verhandlung
unterbrochen worden weil es der mutter
der angeklagten sehr schlecht ging
sie soll nach bild-informationen mit
einer corona infektion im krankenhaus
gelegen haben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren